do you still think the singularity will
happen in 2045
and what does that look like
you know once we can amplify our brain
with computers directly
which will happen in the 2030s that's
going to keep growing and it's another
whole theme which is the exponential
growth of computing power
yeah so looking at Price performance of
computation from 1939 to 2021 right so
that starts with the very first computer
actually created by German during World
War II
and you might have thought that that
might be significant but actually the
Germans
didn't think computers were significant
and they completely rejected it and the
second one is also the zusa 2
and by the way we're looking at a plot
with the x-axis being the year from 1935
to
2025 and on the y-axis and log scale his
competition per second per constant
dollar so dollar normalized to inflation
and it's growing linearly on the log
scale which means it's grown
exponentially the third one was the
British computer
which the Allies did take very seriously
and it cracked the German
code and enables the British to win the
Battle of Britain
which otherwise absolutely would not
have happened if they hadn't cracked the
code using that computer
but that's an exponential graph so a
straight line on that graph is
exponential growth
and you see 80 years of exponential
growth
and I would say about every five years
and this happened shortly before the
pandemic people saying well they call it
Moore's Law which is not the correct
because that's not all Intel in fact it
started decades before intel was even
created it wasn't with transistors
formed into a grid
so it's not just transistor count or
transistor size
difference with relays
then went to vacuum tubes
then went to individual transistors
and and then to integrated circuits yes
um and the integrated circuits actually
starts like in the middle of this graph
and it has nothing to do with Intel
Intel actually was a key part of this
but a few years ago they they stopped
making the fastest chips
uh but if you take the fastest chip of
any technology in that year
you get this kind of graph
and it's it's definitely continuing for
80 years so you don't think Moore's Law
broadly defined is dead
it's been declared dead multiple times
throughout this process I don't like the
term Moore's Law because it has nothing
to do with more or with the Intel but
yes uh the the exponential growth of
computing is continuing yes and has
never stopped from various sources I
mean it went through World War II it
went through Global recessions it's just
continuing
um
and if you continue that out along with
software gains which is another issue
um and they really multiply whatever you
get from software gains you multiply by
the computer gains you get faster and
faster speed
this is actually the fastest computer
models that have been created and that
actually expands
roughly twice a year like every six
months it expands by two
so we're looking at a plot from 2010 to
2022 on the x-axis is the publication
date of the model and the perhaps
sometimes the actual paper associated
with it and on the y-axis is training
compute and flops
and so basically this is
looking at the increase in the not
transistors but the computational power
of
neural networks yeah it's the
computational power that created these
models and that's doubled every six
months which is even faster than the
transistor division yeah
actually since it goes faster than the
amount of cost
this has actually become a greater
investment
to create these but at any rate by the
time you get to 2045
we'll be able to multiply our
intelligence many millions phone
and it's just very hard to imagine what
that would be like and that's the
singularity well we can't even imagine
right that's why we call it the
singularity the singularity in physics
something gets sucked into its
Singularity and you can't tell what's
going on in there
because no information can get out of it
there's various problems with that but
that's the idea it's too
um it's too much beyond what we can
imagine do you think it's possible we
don't notice
that what the singularity actually feels
like
is we just live through it
with exponentially increasing
cognitive capabilities
and we almost because everything's
moving so quickly don't
aren't really able to introspect that
our life has changed yeah but I mean we
will have that much greater capacity to
understand things so we should be able
to look back looking at history
understand history but but we will need
people
basically like you and me to actually
think about these think about it but we
might be distracted by all the other
sources of entertainment and fun
because
the exponential power of intellect is
growing but also there'll be a lot of
fun
the the amount of ways you can have you
know I mean we already have a lot of fun
with computer games and so on that are
really quite remarkable and